All right, so
we've brought back in Jonathan,
to talk a little bit more about
how to move forward with InVision,
making better prototypes.
To start with, how would you go about
making a higher fidelity prototype,
than our current sort of
clickable prototype in InVision?
>> Sure, there's a couple of
ways that you can do this Jay.
The first way is,
we have this option called overlays, so
you can make a modal window or
a drop down menu.
And you simply basically need to
mock up a section of your screen, or
an image of the section of your screen,
and upload that as a separate screen.
And InVision will allow you to
use that screen as an overlay
on top of any existing screen,
so that would be one method.
Another method is you can use advanced
animations through animated gifs.
An animated gif we accept in InVision,
so
that you can demonstrate
in advanced interaction.
>> Right, so as an example,
our current like navigation drawer,
we could use that as an overlay and
it would just sort of show up
actually on top of the other screens.
>> Sure, that's a great example.
>> Perfect.
So what are some other tools
within InVision that we can use
to sort of make better prototypes,
what other options are there?
>> Sure, there are a number of
different options in InVision that
allow you to share out the project.
To see the workflow or the progress of
your screens as you move it through,
the time or
the life cycle of your project.
We also have a feature called boards
that allows you to showcase your
designs in different formats.
So for example, if you have a prototype
that you have in a website.
But then you also want to
display it in a mobile phone or
a tablet, you can display
all those in a single ward.
>> Right.
Okay.
That makes perfect sense.
And then are there best practices for
doing user research with these
clickable InVision prototypes?
>> That's a great question.
The best practice is to
turn off hotspot hinting.
That's an advanced feature,
when you share out of ShareLink.
So when you click the ShareLink button,
there's an advanced option that
allows you to then turn off hotspot
hinting or prevent hotspot hinting.
>> Mm-hm.
>> This allows a user to then, view the
prototype either on a mobile device or
on a desktop computer And
click around interact.
But they're not prompted with
your hotspots, because otherwise,
you'll get feedback that may not
necessarily be natural or organic.
>> Right.
because you'll have maybe a tiny
hotspot.
But if it's brought out in blue and
the user is like, oh, well,
clearly that's a thing because it's
a bright blue square over this image.
>> Exactly.
Yeah.
Preventing those sort of prompts or
tips to the user is always best,
because you want the user to
give you the most natural
feedback that they would otherwise,
give you in a normal environment.
>> Right, you don't want to optimize
this app for being shown in this format,
you want to optimize the app for
being used.
>> Exactly.
>> Awesome.
Thanks for coming in and
giving us so much insight.
>> Thanks for having me.